Bob. The protocol starts with Alice preparing a set of cubits to send to Bob. These cubits contain the
information that will become their shared one-time pad or key. Alice first generates two random sequences of the
same length. One is a random sequence of zeros and ones and the other is a random sequence of x's and z's representing the
basis in which she will prepare her cubits. Then she'll prepare each cubit in a quantum state according to the
combination of the basis and the bit value shown in this chart. So if the bit is zero and the basis is z, she'll
prepare the cubit in the zero state. or if the bit is one and the basis is X, she'll prepare it in the minus state. If
you're not sure what these bases and quantum states are, that's okay. The main point you need to know is that
measurements in each basis only ever have two possible outcomes. 0 or one for the Z- basis and plus or minus for the X
basis. If you measure the state zero in the Z- basis, you will always get zero.
But if you measure that same state in the x basis, you'll get a random result either plus or minus each with 50%
chance. So Alice might prepare a string of cubids like this where here is the random string of
zeros and ones and here is the random string of x's and z's. So the first element in each of her
two sequences was 0 and x. So that means she'll prepare the first cubit in the plus state and so
on. Once she's prepared all of her cubit states, Alice will send Bob these cubits and Bob will randomly choose between X
and Z as the basis in which to measure each one. So we now add some rows to the
chart to represent Bob's choices and measurements. So here are Bob's
measurements and basis choices. And here are his measurement results of the cubits that Alice sent him. Finally, Bob
can convert each measurement to a bit using the same table that Alice used to prepare her cubits. When he measures the
zero or the plus state, he assigns the bit value zero. And where he measures the one or the minus state, he puts a
one. So Bob's final bit string is this final row.
Note that when the bases of Alice's preparation step and Bob's measurement step match, then their bits will match,
too. But if Alice chooses to prepare Z and Bob measures in X or vice versa,
then Alice and Bob's corresponding bits won't necessarily be the same. So, a way they can both agree upon a bit string
for their one-time pad is by calling each other up and telling each other which bases they used for each cubit.
When the bases match, they keep the bit and when they don't, they throw it away.
So, in this case, Alice and Bob will both agree upon a bit string of 0 0 1 0
0. How does this scheme protect against unnoticed eavesdroppers? Well, let's see what happens when such an easedropper
named Eve intercepts the cubits that Alice sends to Bob. She doesn't know what state these cubits are in or how
Alice prepared them. So, thanks to the uncertainty principle and something called the no cloning theorem, she can't
just make an identical copy of the cubits to pass along to Bob. If she could, then she would be able to
eavesdrop without detection. Instead, she guesses a basis in which to measure each cubit, measures them, and then
prepares a new set of spoof cubits to send along to Bob. There are other sneakier ways that Eve could try to
learn about the cubits, but none of them get around the uncertainty principle.
So, we'll just assume this straightforward method of Eve's dropping. Here's a chart describing
Alice's preparation, Eve's interception, and Bob's final measurement. So now when
Alice and Bob talk on the phone to compare their bases, they'll decide to keep these bits for their key, but the
bits don't match. This is because Bob was measuring cubits that Eve prepared, not the original cubits that Alice had.
If they compare a subset of the bits in their bitst strings with one another, they'll see that some don't match and
assume that there must have been an eavesdropper. So since Eve was discovered, Alice and Bob will throw
away their bitst strings and start the protocol all over again. But if Eve hadn't listened in and the subset of the
bits that Alice and Bob compared matched, then they could go ahead and use the remaining bits that they didn't
compare as their shared key. Once Alice and Bob have a shared key, then Alice can send encrypted messages to Bob, and
Bob is the only one who can decrypt them using the key. Now that we've gone through the protocol, let's try it on a
quantum computer. There are a couple things to keep in mind for this experiment. First,
BB-84 is really only useful if Alice and Bob are far away from each other. For the experiment we're about to do, Alice
and Bob are on the same quantum chip. So, this experiment won't be useful for exchanging private information, but it's
still a good conceptual demonstration of BB-84.
Second, real quantum computers have noise. So even if Alice's preparation basis matches Bob's measurement basis
and there was no easedropper, there's still a small chance that they will measure different bits due to errors in
the quantum computer. When they're comparing their bitst strings to check for eavesdroppers, they need to have some tolerance for errors before they
conclude that an eavesdropper must have been messing with them and they throw the whole key out. Now with those
caveats, let's start with an experiment with no eavesdropper. First, we randomly
generate three different bit strings, each with 20 bits. The first is Alice's initial bit
string. The second is a list of bases in which Alice will prepare her cubits.
Here we've chosen zero to represent the Z basis and one to represent the X basis. The final list is the bases in
which Bob will measure each cubit. Based on those three lists, we can make a circuit diagram with instructions for
Alice's preparation and Bob's measurements. All cubits start in the zero state. So to prepare her cubits in
the Z basis, Alice either does nothing for the zero state or applies a knot or X gate shown as the blue boxes labeled X
for the one state. To prepare in the X basis, she applies either a hatamard gate which takes zero to the plus state
or a not gate followed by a hatamard to prepare the minus state. Then she sends the cubits to Bob. The next set of boxes
in the circuit represents Bob's measurements. To measure in the Z basis, he doesn't need to apply any more gates.